wer ohne wird es ungefähr die schrägste
zu weit geht es runter alter und tom
lebt immer noch
doch nicht immer
servus es geht so nicht willkommen zur
zweiten folge von better together
heute kommt ja wissen drogen kaufen
junge weiße flugplatz beste route junge
du musst am bahnhof berne die drugs
willst nicht nicht flugplatz nicht viel
platz am flugplatz sitzen hier war immer
an den herd junge akademiker flugplatz
was schreiben die von enya des niedrig
halten
okay okay ist das ja aus wie ein
widerspruch ist alter junge das wird das
war ja der rastet aus kann's mir helfen
kannst du helfen ich kann nicht erklären
es darum dass donnerstag 04 11 wird dann
kann man hasst du fast food essen
hast du was zu essen
oder irgendwas ich hab nix wartet ja wat
ich hab' ich habe ihnen holz ich komme
hierher komme wo bist du
dre komm raus sie drin da andere seite
junge andere seite ich kann nicht mehr
sprechen
fakt ist ja bin ich warte auf
ich habe da beim haushalt ausgang
jung ich brauch jetzt fuß oder auf
einmal habe ich von der für etwas essen
danke man heute im rat münchen hier
nimmt nimmt ich brauche bist du die
vorrüstung ich versuche alter egal ob
diese rinne einfach noch mal gegen die
junge liebe es ich hab nix ich hab gar
nicht seine rüstung jung und dumm ist
heftig ich hab's gesehen waren die die
eltern beste was man jetzt hier so wenig
keine ahnung
da musst du dich schämen sagt er sagt
dass das equipment für einmal war ich
bin hier wieder andere drogen flecken
der junge werther wachstum
du bist du ich will ich bin im bahnhof
ja ich komme auch ein paar wir müssen
gucken winter bekommen darüber da wo man
darüber junge das wird so peinlich alter
weise sein kommt dem und dann ein guter
weg
das kann er nicht machen da vor dem 2
nein hab ich dir genommen hatte ja okay
okay hast du bitte sagt mir du hast du
dir also ich hab schon zehn oder als
auch schon ein ich habe schon eine okay
okay was auch wir müssen jetzt hier
wirklich alles ab und schalte sich
minute
wir müssen alles absuchen ich komme um
gegen schwerte ist so ungefähr wissen
die wand abbauen all den baum erfreulich
entwickelt da draußen wo bist du bist du
im turm ganz oben ich erwarte ich bin
das ich bin ein bisschen ich lauf hier
hoch technik ist nicht raus hat noch ein
wenig zusammen das ist alles gelungen
hast du hast du hast was essen ich hab
halbe leben und dreck nicht löse das
problem ist kommt mir die leute frage ob
uns jemand spendet kommt ja ok ok in den
zug rein in den zug rein machen wir denn
wenn die leute kommen
ja ohne wird davon ist einer davon mit
seiner ist linke steigt ja so ist es
einfach
ich kann hier spenden ich kann
versprechen ich schon lange nicht mehr
ich kann nicht gründen
ich kann auch ich kann auch sprechen
aber jetzt auch nicht mehr mit den
spenden der gigant alter hast du auch
kein essen junge was ist das für ein
freudiges rot ist ungefähr alle gesetze
aufgehoben
doch er hat essen wo bist du bist junge
ergibt ein steak danke danke danke danke
danke ich fragen hast du noch was für
bitte mit besucher alter und hält euch
vielleicht hatte ich fast radomski
alabama ist es nicht und kurzweilig
plätze der wollte in der hoffnung etwas
zu essen
davon ist das kannst du doch sprinten
nein nein ich war geboten nicht im ernst
mit im paket nein nein nein nein nein
dom ist da hinten der ist gar nicht da
eindruck dass kommt kommt zurück muss
dazu muss ich raus boxen
ich mag den boden
die junge du musst rücker ich denke
boden fest du musst dich raus cox bitte
komm zurück kommt
aber wenn die wut gibt den kopf kommen
bitte zurück er gibt mir mut
ja da kommt dann kommen sofort zurück
zur brücke kommen sofort zurück ja danke
gott komme jetzt sofort zurück du musst
dich bevor die strecke fest wenn mich
jemand wenn mich jemand erwischt da bin
ich ich bin gefundenes fressen die tiere
mich sofort ich komme sofort siegert
eine kleine sorge kommt dann nehme ich
jetzt nicht angreifen
oh jetzt kommt ein wo willst du wo wir
hier hier hatte er zeigt ihm wieder
danke man ja und wut fast nichts
bekommen also was ich brauch ich muss
mich bei noch drei arbeiten zu reden
aber ich kann das hier geben und kein
bisschen jung aber gehen nicht drauf
junge du gehst drauf dabei lastet
ich hab' ich habe dreieinhalb herzen
mann
wir brauchen junge wo ich wollte schon
sagen gott seine stimme in der teams
erlaubt variante alter kommt zum lasst
uns in ruhe ohne [ __ ] alter immer
noch immer stirbt sie
was hast du getan hast auf den du da
muss ich da muss ich dich jetzt rechnen
jetzt wohl gestorben ist muss sich das
wahre battle gegen gegen dong austragen
alter an die hängt das komplette werk
machen wir halt noch drin hängt alles
von ihr
was ist das für eine runde leute das ist
ja so sparen geht auf seiner vorsicht
vorrichtungen flughafen flughafen das
liegt darum da ist doch jung wie op-art
er schreibt nicht ergreift an er wird
angreifen oder erwarte er kräftig gas
krieg oben links ist noch einer da oben
ist er nämlich die filter du musst mich
rächen er kommt er kommt jan o das
gibt's dann ist der spaß die leute falls
ihr vielleicht eine wiederholung vorhält
dann könnt ihr das gerne die kommentare
könnt gerne lassen euch die folge
gefallen hat ansonsten sieht man in der
nächsten folge wieder laut reinhardt und
checkt alive ab dessen beschreibung